the nebia by moan quattro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 percent as much water but with a
super high pressure spray click the link
below and use the code pacman for 10
off all nebia products
today we're going to take a deep dive at
the topic of the war on drugs something
we've been covering on the program for a
long time we have covered the ins and
outs we've done interviews we've heard
from you
and today
our deep dive the war on drugs in the
united states of america welcome back to
the show i mentioned at the beginning of
the show we're going to be at net roots
nation from june 16th to 19th in
minneapolis there is going to be a david
pakman show and best of the left podcast
and at least one or two other shows that
i'm sure you've heard of meetup it's
going to be at a restaurant or bar near
the conference in downtown minneapolis
probably thursday night which i think is
the 16th
don't know the exact details yet stay
tuned should be a good time and also
this is the time to become a david
pakman show member not only lewis we're
actually we haven't even mentioned this
but we're on the cusp as a result of the
success of the membership program of
being able to further expand programming
i think that's as far as i'll say for
now right let's leave it at that leave
it at that but we are giving away this
ipad i have here
you become a member you get 10 entries
into the ipad giveaway you can always
just sign up for our newsletter or like
us on facebook you get one entry that
way and you get the commercial free
podcast the bonus show produced by
producer lewis motomedy the full five
and a half year archive of the show it's
really a pretty long list of benefits i
have to say
in those first few shows
wow right august of 05 is is not our
best work let me put it that way i
wasn't even involved so
i cannot be held responsible for for
that mess a number of major
international leaders are basically
pleading with the us and the world to
get smart and stop the war on drugs and
we've talked about the war on drugs off
and on for a while and
it's come up on the show in a number of
different ways really though louis we
are starting to see more and more
evidence that the way the united states
is handling non-violent drug offenses
and the criminalization of certain drugs
is really just not working for a variety
of reasons and that's old news i know
many conservatives say that we
progressives who are into the
decriminalization of drugs it's because
we're potheads and that's really not the
case i'm not a marijuana user quite
frankly
let me be complete without identifying
anybody specific there's some marijuana
users
at my condo complex which i find
incredibly annoying i hate the smell i
really wish that they just wouldn't do
it i really wish they would actually
move out to be completely honest and i
hope they don't listen to the show i
can't imagine they do but really the
amount of problems and the amount of
waste
in terms of resources and money that is
going into
the war on drugs is getting to the point
where it just belies any kind of logic
and reason
lewis is stunned he doesn't even know
how to respond
i agree
there's a number of countries that have
enacted harm reduction strategies which
include syringe access medication public
health initiatives united kingdom
switzerland germany austria australia
they've all had reduced rates of hiv
transmission among people who inject
drugs
especially when compared to countries
that are actively resisting these
strategies like thailand and russia and
i think it's just obvious but beyond
that look at the problems that
california is having as a result of
overcrowding of prisons to the point
where we just heard conservatives flip
out 10 days ago because they were
considering the release of some
non-violent offenders and wait a second
why are so many of those in there
because of over criminal criminalization
of non-violent drug offenses
i actually saw an interesting study i've
seen a documentary and read about
portugal in 2001 being the first
european country to decriminalize the
use and possession of all absolutely all
drugs
okay
tons of criticism about this people
saying it would lead to greater drug use
and the problems associated with it now
a couple of weeks ago on the show i
mentioned that i thought ron paul was
being a little silly when he said if you
were to legalize heroin
would anyone in this room use it raise
your hand and nobody did and that was
taken for ron paul as a sign that people
wouldn't start using heroin if it was
legal i completely disagree with that
premise
the question is on the whole
in term taking into consideration all of
the factors including law enforcement
being able to focus in other areas
focus on violent offenses
the possibility of taxing
and actually deriving revenue
from certain drug sales and the prison
situation which in this country is just
it's appalling louis
it actually in portugal did not really
it went okay i mean i can't say it was a
just a blinding success but it really
went okay removing criminality and
combining it with very accessible
therapy
and substance abuse programs have
actually reduced the burden on law
enforcement and problematic drug use has
actually been reduced
now that's not to say that there aren't
people doing drugs that more wouldn't
have that wouldn't have otherwise we
can't say that but what the indication
is is that problematic drug use and the
the
cost in terms of resources government
resources has actually been alleviated
significantly right at the same time if
we can we can take care of different
problems
without
making
legalizing marijuana and don't get me
wrong i'm a fan of legalizing marijuana
but like we just did here in
massachusetts
decriminalization the decriminalization
right
and you can expand on that too i mean
you can make it uh a non-criminal
offense to have here it's what is it
it's an ounce i wouldn't know if you
have more than an ounce
you can get hit with intent to
distribute right i mean we could get rid
of that too
there are steps you can take without
doing a whole nationwide
decriminalization of all drugs i agree
there's a new study that shows that tons
of people
are ditching opioids and using marijuana
to treat pain as well as anxiety and
depression this is a a new study
published in the journal of pain
research the study is called cannabis as
a substitute for prescription drugs a
cross-sectional study it surveyed three
thousand people from fifty states where
there are sort of different degrees of
marijuana legality and it found that
nearly half of people who use marijuana
at least once within the prior 90 days
were using it as a substitute for
prescription drugs to treat either pain
anxiety or depression there apparently
and this is very interesting there was
no difference
in the rate at which people were
replacing medication with marijuana in
states where it is legal and in states
uh where it is not legal it appears as
though the legality of marijuana is not
deterring people but that doesn't mean
that it makes sense to send people to
jail for choosing marijuana to treat
their pain symptoms it's just sort of an
interesting statistical
note to make so this means that
not only are people using marijuana to
replace opioids which are way more
addictive by the way that about half of
people doing it are uh using marijuana
to replace prescription medications of
other kinds and the most recently uh the
most the most
frequently replaced drugs are
painkillers which includes opioids as
well as other addictive narcotics 13
were replacing depression and anxiety
drugs and there's sort of less uh
there's less research there than there
is into marijuana as an alternative to
painkillers but very interesting
nonetheless well it seems as though
marijuana distracts from pain more so
than it does counteract it as opiates do
so you can get your mind onto other
things and as you talked about i think
you know if you have other ailments like
perhaps nausea maybe you're going
through chemo and you have to get some
food into your system marijuana is an
easy way to do that because everyone
knows it makes you more hungry appetite
stimulant as they say now this isn't to
say that marijuana is the best treatment
or even a good treatment for depression
or anxiety for example and we're also
not saying that smoking things is good
for you right when you smoke anything
and you're inhaling smoke that's not
good for you you don't have to smoke it
you could use a vaporizer or eat it what
we're talking about here is medical
applications of cannabis and the notion
of people replacing opioids and other
narcotics with marijuana which is
unquestionably more benign
it seems like an incredibly preferable
situation from a public health
perspective and of course we need more
research into how marijuana can treat
different pathologies this includes the
ones i've listed but this also includes
others and the classification of
marijuana as a schedule one drug
continues to create major hurdles it's
great that states are legalizing but as
long as it remains a schedule one drug
federally it is going to be difficult to
learn as much as we can about the
possible medical approaches and uh look
at what we've learned right from the
decriminalization and legalization that
we've seen so far legalization in
colorado crime didn't go up very
interesting and important data
legalization removes power from the
black market you still have a black
market when you legalize pot the selling
of untaxed pot for example selling of
pot to miners who would not be able to
go into a dispensary and actually buy it
but it shrinks the black market
drastically and then also higher than
expected revenues for states to put into
addiction treatment education public
health etc and one of the most important
elements of this
is replacing really dangerous and
addictive opiates which are part of the
reason for the opioid epidemic right
many people don't get how this works
they they associate people on heroin
with um you know homelessness or mental
illness or whatever right there's these
sort of stereotypes about it
many of the people that are ending up
addicted to heroin
are starting with a legal opioid
prescription from a doctor for a
legitimate injury or procedure that
they've had
they get addicted to that legal
prescription so they start buying opioid
pills on the street and then they
realize wow the pills are way more
expensive than heroin i'll just switch
to heroin that that is a path that has
been widely identified why not try to
circumvent that with cannabis a lot of
people seem to talk about marijuana as
if it's some big panacea and will solve
all of our ailments it's not to say that
marijuana can't have negative health
consequences sure can but given the
alternatives of people using opiates and
then moving on to stronger more
effective drugs like heroin yeah it's a
much better option how can anyone argue
against that and yet another study that
is pointing us in that direction
tony wrote in tony says hey david which
drugs do you think should be legalized
or decriminalized so number one
it's good that you're making the
distinction between legalized and
decriminalized because legalization and
decriminalization uh are are very
different things and also it's important
to distinguish between
trafficking and personal use okay so
let's go in order all drug use and drug
possession for personal amounts should
be decriminalized period uh legalization
absolutely for marijuana
and for other drugs i'm open to
discussion you look i believe it's
denver that's testing legalizing
mushrooms as an example
i
have less of a fixed opinion about
the legalization of some drugs i've not
seen good reasons to legalize
recreational cocaine or heroin for
example i'm very clear that possessing
cocaine or heroin for personal use
should not be a crime
using cocaine or heroin should not be a
crime
uh but the recreational legalization of
cocaine and heroin i i just i've not
seen a good argument for that and i'm
willing to have my mind changed now this
gets us to a really important element of
this debate that a lot of people miss a
lot of people seem not to understand
that when you talk about legalization or
decriminalization of any drug
you're not talking about it being legal
to be trafficking in those drugs 10
pounds of marijuana or a kilo of coke or
whatever whether you decriminalize or
legalize
that is likely still going to be
criminal and when you think about it
alcohol is legal recreationally
cigarettes are legal recreationally it
is still against the law to traffic and
alcohol or cigarettes without doing it
you know on the record as a business in
the way that the the guidelines say that
you should you can have that debate and
i'm i'm glad to have it uh but it's
important to understand and i think that
there are a lot of bad faith actors on
the anti-decriminalization
anti-legalization tends to be the
political right in the united states who
either
are misunderstanding or they are
deliberately conflating the
decriminalization or legalization of the
trafficking of drugs versus legalization
and decriminalization of amounts for
personal use and these are very very
different conversations so my question
to you today is
what is the strongest argument
for recreational legalization of drugs
like cocaine and heroin i am 110 on
board with marijuana uh i would sooner
make cigarettes illegal than say that
marijuana should remain criminal for use
and possession
uh but i i simply have not seen a good
case made for why there should be
recreationally legal cocaine or heroin
but if you've got a good argument to
make along those lines by all means get
in touch and then we can talk about it
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving showerhead starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebbia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just a hundred and
nineteen dollars but nebia is giving you
ten percent off when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video
i'm joined today by johann hari author
of the book chasing the scream the first
and last days of the war on drugs johan
there's so much interesting stuff in
here as far as addiction goes as far as
the origins of the war on drugs the
place where i want to start with you is
let's go back to the origins of the war
on drugs many right-wingers in the u.s
that i speak to
do not want to concede that there were
some racially tinged elements to the
beginning of the war on drugs in the
united states let's talk about that
first
if you'd said to me when i started the
journey on doing this book four years
ago why did the war on drugs start i
would have guessed it was for the
reasons that your average person on the
street would give if you stop them now
you know you don't want kids to use
drugs you don't want people to become
addicted what was fascinating going back
and looking all through the archives is
there wasn't just a racially tinged
element to it the entire debate was
about race those things that we think
about barely came up it's really
shocking when you read it i tell the
story in the book i tell this story in
the book through the story of how billy
holliday the great jazz singer was
stalked and killed by the man who
launched the modern war on drugs harry
anslinger and it's a really striking
story you know she stands on stage in
new york city in 1939 she sings the song
strange fruit a great anti-lynching song
and that night the federal bureau of
narcotics ordered her to stop singing
that song and it's a really weird place
you think to begin the story you think
well what was the narcotics bureau got
to do with the song it was founded
the the drug war was founded by this
crazy racist called harry anslinger
really he's the he's the most
influential person who no one's ever
heard of and he was obsessed with billy
holliday because she was
african-american not because she was an
addict it's very really at the same time
he finds out two super famous people are
heroin addicts judy garland and billy
holliday judy garland he advises her to
take slightly longer vacations and
reassures the studio she's going to be
fine billy holliday he has her destroyed
even on her deathbed he has her arrested
lots of her friends thought that he
effectively killed her you know so he
really tells you a lot about the origins
of the drug war that story and given the
sort of dim-witted uh uh start that we
got to this drug war it shouldn't really
come as much of a surprise that the the
results we claim to be waiting for right
which are reductions in crime reductions
and drug usage don't really seem to be
happening as a result
well it's the opposite it in fact
creates an enormous amount of crime i
spent a lot of time in the book with a
transsexual crack dealer in brownsville
in brooklyn called chino harding whose
story i tell an incredible person who
was conceived when his his mom who was a
crack addict was raped by his dad he was
the nypd officer and chino's story i
think tells you about the dynamic that
runs all over the world when you ban
drugs they don't disappear right no one
watching your show is so foolish they
think that what happens is they're
transferred from the people who used to
control them before the drug war and the
people who control them in lots of
countries today doctors and pharmacists
and they're transferred into the hands
of armed criminal gangs now that creates
a whole wave of violence that otherwise
wouldn't exist if you or me go into your
local liquor store and we try to steal
the beer or the vodka they just call the
cops right we'll be taken away that
liquor store doesn't have to be violent
or intimidating if we go up to your
local weed dealer or your local coke
dealer and we try to steal what they're
selling obviously they can't ring the
cops the cops would arrest them they
have to be violent and intimidating they
have to stage acts of theatrical
violence that are so extreme that no one
would dare to take them off milton
friedman the nobel prize-winning
economist calculated there are an
additional 10
000 murders every year in the united
states as a direct result of that
dynamic and it's not just dealers and
cops who die in it it's a lot of people
who get caught in the way now that's
extreme enough in the united states i
went to northern mexico i interviewed
one of the only people who's ever been
at the heart of one of the deadliest
mexican drug cartels and lived to tell
the story of how he butchered him
beheaded over 70 people that dynamic has
destroyed mexico and i think a fact that
every american should know michelle
leonhardt the head of the dea the drug
enforcement agency a woman whose wages
you pay was asked what she thought of
the 60 000 civilian deaths in mexico in
the last seven years
and the exact phrase you used was it's a
sign of success in the war on drugs that
should be a national and international
scandal americans are better than that
and we're just starting to get some of
the data now from the legalization i
don't want to call them experiments
necessarily but the the initial
instances of legalization here in the us
colorado and some data from washington
but we can look at some other countries
to look at longer term
decriminalization and legalization and
get a sense of what the impact could be
right
it's really important you're totally
right it's really important to
understand there's no reason to have an
abstract conversation about what ending
the drug war looks like it is being
tried in practice in lots of places
today and i went to those places to see
what they look like i'll give you one
example for example portugal in the year
2000 had one of the worst drug problems
in europe one percent of the population
was addicted to heroin which is kind of
mind-blowing and every year they tried
the american way more and more they
arrested more people they imprisoned
more people and every year the problem
got worse
in the year 2000 the prime minister and
the leader of the opposition get
together got together and effectively
said look we can't go on like this
let's set up a panel of scientists and
doctors to figure out what would
genuinely solve this problem so the
panel goes away for a year and a half
and it came back and it said
decriminalize
all drugs from cannabis to crack but and
this is the crucial thing take all the
money we used to spend on arresting and
imprisoning drug addicts i.e making them
worse and use all that money to
reconnect them with the society and it's
important to understand what that means
partly that's things that we think of as
drug treatment in britain america um
you know rehab uh psychological support
they have real value but the biggest
thing was something much more simple it
was about going about making sure that
every addict in portugal had something
to get out of bed for in the morning so
say you used to be a mechanic when
you're ready they'll go to a garage and
they'll say if you employ this guy for a
year we'll pay half his wages
really simple stuff micro loans for
addicts to set up small businesses it's
been nearly 15 years since this
experiment began in portugal the
decriminalization of all drugs and the
results are in injecting drug use is
down by fifty percent five zero percent
overdose deaths are massively down hiv
transmission among adults is massively
down street crime is significantly down
one of the ways you know it really
worked i would interview this guy called
figuera who led the opposition to the
decriminalization at the time he was the
top drug cop in portugal and he said to
me everything i said would happen didn't
happen and everything the other side
said would happen did and he talked
about how about how he felt ashamed that
he'd spent 20 years arresting and
harassing drug addicts prior to the
decriminalization and he hoped the whole
world follows portugal's example
everywhere i went but they moved beyond
the drug war there were when i tell
these stories in the book not only is
there incredible successes there's
there's very few people who want to go
back yeah and we recently interviewed a
police officer from law enforcement
against prohibition who had a very
similar stories as the ones you tell i
want to get your thoughts on
legalization versus decriminalization
because even amongst those in the u.s
who don't want to see all drugs be
illegal there's not necessarily
consensus about legalization versus
decriminalization and for which drugs so
what how can we think about that it's
worth explaining to people the
difference decriminalization is
generally used to mean where you don't
punish people for using it or possessing
it for them as for their own personal
use legalization is where you open up
some route for them to legally buy it
and the way i think the crudest way to
put it is decriminalization shuts down
orange is the new black legalization
shuts down breaking bad so
decriminalization gets rid of the
problem where you're pointlessly
arresting and imprisoning drug users and
making their lives worse
breaking bad sorry legalization is where
you reclaim the drugs from armed
criminal gangs and bankrupt those armed
criminal gangs now i'm in favor of both
so decriminalization is a route to
legalization i think decriminalization
is a good start but legalization is
important it's important to understand
though what that means
sometimes when you talk about legalizing
drugs people think you know you're
talking about there being a crack isle
in cvs no one wants that maybe there's
some crazy extreme libertarian who wants
that but virtually nobody wants that to
understand
again there's nothing abstract about
this switzerland is an extremely
conservative country if it were an
american state it would be pretty much
like utah right i'm a swiss citizen as
well as a british citizen
and switzerland has legalized heroin and
it's important to understand what that
means
uh we think about how we regulate drugs
already today right there are some drugs
that you can go and just buy as an adult
like alcohol a very powerful and toxic
drug there are other drugs you have to
go to the doctor to get right
legalization is about expanding that
kind of regulation to cover different
drugs so there's some will regulate like
alcohol
like marijuana in switzerland with
heroin they obviously haven't done that
what they've done is if you're a heroin
addict you go to the doctor
the doctor will assign you to if he
believes you he'll assign you to a
clinic you can go to that clinic up to
three times a day and you'll be given
heroin and you use it there and what's
really striking is i went to this clinic
in geneva
it looks like a fancy manhattan
hairdressers people going in the morning
they inject their heroin and then they
go off to work overwhelmingly they have
jobs they get their lives back together
do you know how many deaths from
overdose they've been in that clinic
since it began 20 years ago
zero none not a single one deaths from
overdose don't happen anymore in in in
geneva where that clinic is
really striking in vancouver when they
opened a similar project massive falling
overdose deaths so it's important
legalization is already being tried
with both uh what we think of as soft
drugs in colorado washington with really
great results and with harder drugs in
switzerland and in both places you know
switzerland
as i say very conservative country they
have voted twice in referenda by 70
to keep heroin legal for addicts that
tells you something about how well it
works not least because there was a
massive falling crime a burglary fell
enormously street prostitution ended
really striking results last thing i
want to talk about johan and the limited
time we have left is back to this topic
of addiction specifically and you talk
in your book
about the studies that have been done
with rats which have really changed our
understanding of what it is that makes
people addicted and it's not quite so
simple as heroin makes you addicted to
heroin
yeah it's fascinating series of
experiments were done earlier in the
20th century they're really simple
experiments you can your viewers can do
them at home if they're feeling a little
bit sadistic you get a rat you put it in
a cage and you give it two water bottles
one is just water and one is water laced
with either heroin or cocaine if you do
that the rat will almost always prefer
the drugged water and will almost always
kill itself that's where we get our
theory of addiction from
that's what we think addiction is in the
70s a guy called bruce alexander comes
along a professor in vancouver
and he said hang on a minute we're
putting the rat in an empty cage
he's got nothing to do except use these
drugs let's do this differently so bruce
built rat park and rat park is like
heaven for rats everything iraq would
want in life it's got a rat park it's
got cheese and colored balls and tunnels
loads of friends that can have loads of
sex
and they've got both the water bottles
the normal water and the drugged water
but here's the fascinating thing in rat
park they don't like the drug water they
hardly ever use it none of them ever
overdose now there's really important
human examples of this they're happening
all around us i tell you about and have
been running out of time but what bruce
says is this shows that both the right
wing and left-wing theories of addiction
are wrong the right-wing theory is it's
a moral failing you're a hedonist the
left-wing theory is your brain gets
hijacked bruce says it's not your brain
it's not immorality it's your cage
addiction is largely an adaptation to
your environment and there's really
interesting human examples i can tell
you about if we've got time but that
really shows
the folly of the drug war approach you
know if what's driving addiction is
disconnection and pain
the idea that we should impose more
disconnection we should in fact make it
impossible for them to ever get jobs and
more pain on them and the belief that
that will make them stop is mad i went
out in arizona as i described in chasing
the screen with a group of women forced
to go out on chain gangs wearing
t-shirts saying i was a drug addict and
made to dig graves those women are never
going to work again i went to the hole
the solitary confinement unit where
they're put and i saw these women these
drug addicts left in this cage and i
suddenly thought wow this is the closest
you could possibly get to actually
literally recreating the cages that
guarantee addiction in in animals and
this is what we do to stop them being
addicted it's madness it's total madness
and there's obviously so much more to
talk about and what i would love to do
is once we get more data not only from
colorado but from the other states that
are that are uh decriminalizing and
legalizing in the us we'll have you back
and we'll really dig into that data but
in the meantime i'll remind the audience
that johann hari's book is chasing the
scream the first and last days of the
war on drugs comprehensive overview of
all of the elements that play into
modern day war on drugs johann thank you
for being on thanks david i'll just say
that people can get more information at
the website
well i'm thrilled to be on your show
thanks david
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
uh all right let's try our next caller
from the three two one area code caller
from three two one are you there
hello
who's this can you hear me we can hear
you it's michael michael hewitt right
i was wondering uh with the vicious
cycles that are happening in today's
youth uh with especially with the opioid
epidemic and how
people today
take these prescription pills and
they get into an addiction then whenever
the pills stop coming they get into
these harder drugs and then those harder
drugs spread out to to the youth to my
generation
at what point does uh
the us look at its system on on the war
on drugs and go
we have failed on this and we should
probably look at other places that have
uh better succeeded in in this war on
drugs such as portugal where they have
uh lowered their hiv rates through
through the legalization and heroin the
heroin epidemic in portugal has now been
substantially lowered because of this
right
conflating a couple different issues so
number one is the sort of war on drug
status quo and to answer the question
when does the us seriously rethink that
it's when our priorities change away
from using the war on drugs to derive
law enforcement revenue and to
incarcerate people so that that would
need to change for us to seriously
rethink the war on drugs you're also
referring to this cycle that exists
within opiates which is where people are
often ending up addicted to heroin
because they end up buying
painkillers on the street because they
were prescribed painkillers by a doctor
often over prescribed and with not
enough supervision and that is a circle
that we need to interrupt and it's
related to the war on drugs but it's
also sort of its own problem michael
okay and what could we do as a
uh society to
uh bring actual change to to these
problems
yeah there's a couple different things i
mean certainly you've got a d you have
to decriminalize
uh drugs you have to make drugs an issue
of public health rather than of
criminality and of law enforcement
there's no question that you also need
to reschedule certain drugs the current
scheduling of drugs makes absolutely no
sense the idea of cannabis marijuana
scheduled as a schedule 1 drug when i
believe cocaine is a schedule 2 drug at
this time
that doesn't make sense so there's a lot
of really specific changes that could be
made that i've talked about but we
really need to have a wholesale
reorganization of how we deal with drugs
is there any way to
change how the police force is uh
getting paid so then these uh
you no not even
morally wrong uh infractions are not
taken upon the youth and
and basically screwing over their entire
lives because of a petty petty marijuana
offense yes certainly decriminalization
and also you've got to deal also with
diversion programs you can't be putting
young kids into the system and then
basically saying to them you're going to
be part of this system indefinitely
right that that's what you're saying to
a kid when they're 17 and they start to
interact with the law enforcement system
over something like drug possession no
doubt about it
so to take a little bit of a break from
the presidential race we actually got
some very good news
on tuesday the war on drugs
was crushed on election day at least as
much as you could crush it in one day in
every state where marijuana legalization
or decriminalization
or progressivization of drug policy was
on the ballot it won
in arizona
montana new jersey and south dakota
voters legalized recreational marijuana
incredible
in mississippi and even south dakota
voters legalized medical
marijuana south dakota had both uh
legalized recreational and legalized
medical
in oregon voters decriminalized but not
legalized all drugs including cocaine
and heroin also in oregon voters
legalize the use of psilocybin a
psychedelic drug found in so-called
magic mushrooms in specifically
supervised therapeutic uses that this is
huge
oregon also um uh is uh so what's going
to happen in oregon is you will no
longer be punished with jail or prison
time for
small amounts of possession of any drug
that includes cocaine and heroin if you
get caught with cocaine and heroin you
can either pay a hundred dollar fine or
do a completed health assessment the
details of which i don't yet know but we
will find out in washington dc voters
decriminalized psychedelic plants also
following following the lead of several
other cities
and again oregon the first state in the
united states in modern times to
decriminalize all drugs marijuana is now
legalized in 15 states plus washington
dc
although washington dc still does not
allow sales all measures won by at least
five percentage points in every state
this really is not hugely shocking
over the last decade we've seen polls
show marijuana legalization is
increasingly popular in many polls even
among republicans there is support for
at least marijuana decriminalization
this is a big rejection of the war on
drugs it starts to signal a major shift
in u.s drug policy it's going to push
for more of the disassembly of the war
on drugs but another thing that's
important to remember is
we are getting the first steps here but
we still need to deal with the criminal
justice component so for example if
anybody
uh has a record now
for
in oregon if you have a record for
possession of small amounts of cocaine
which now are legal decriminalized i
should say not legalized decriminalized
uh what happens to your record it should
probably be expunged and that is the
next step that is the next step here
that's the next forefront legal cannabis
you know nice for people looking to go
to a nice store and get
you know curated curated pot but the
criminal justice piece is more difficult
and it has to come right after this and
hopefully we will see that also i expect
to see the tobacco industry get more and
more into cannabis and there's also real
opportunities in terms of taking the tax
revenue that this will generate and
really doing great things with it we're
going to be discussing it more we're
going to be looking to places like
colorado even massachusetts as potential
models of how this can be managed how
the money can be used but a major win
against the war on drugs on tuesday and
we'll keep talking about ballot
initiatives because there's a lot of
really interesting stuff to discuss all
right let's go back to the phones and
try our next caller from the 864 area
code caller from 864 can you hear me
what's on your mind today
hi um
yeah
basically i had two precursors to my
question wow um
first uh the the definition of terrorism
when you google it
on dictionary.com is the use of violence
and threats to intimidating coerce
especially for political purposes and
also we know for a fact
that the war on drugs was specifically
started for political means
and they have used coercion
violence and threats
for decades
is this somehow not a form of terrorism
in itself yeah you know i've heard this
argued before and i guess we're you know
we can slice and dice the definition of
terrorism a number of different ways
another popular way to frame this sort
of same terrorism definition debate is
uh are any military actions by a country
uh in some way shape or form terrorism
because they often use violence and are
meant to have uh sort of political out
outcomes or repercussions my question to
you would be this what difference would
it make practically in other words we
know the racist origins of the war on
drugs we know it's disproportionate
racial impact economic impact on poor
people we know about
uneven policing based on poor
neighborhoods and rich neighborhoods and
we know about how the war on drugs as it
exists was sort of a reaction to the
civil rights act of the 1960s so what
would change if we said hey you know
what it is a form of terrorism
well honestly i would like us to adapt
what is going on in portugal where they
have decriminalized and actually the the
world health organization is all uh
suggested to the us to decriminalize as
well okay no i agree with that but hold
on a second let's walk through it piece
by piece if we can
let's say we agree that the war on drugs
is a form of terrorism
what impact would that have on any of
our policy
well it could
help to push to stop the war on drugs
that that's
what i would i think our our goal would
be and pushing for it would it though
because has talking about american
foreign policy abroad is terrorism in
some circles changed american foreign
policy abroad
no no yeah so i'm just not sure i mean i
think it's a very interesting academic
question and i'm not to be to be clear
i'm not writing it off as as a silly
question right i think it's interesting
when we look at the actual definition of
terrorism it's sometimes easy to forget
how much of what
happens domestically or even that the
u.s is involved in internationally could
arguably fall under that definition i
just am unsure
what it
we just don't call it that
okay all right well interesting
interesting question i would just
encourage you to think about you know if
we want to focus on that we should
really be sure that it will help us get
to a political outcome that we want and
if it won't it might not be the best uh
best use of our time thanks for the call
really appreciate it very very
interesting topic
let's go to a caller from the 413 area
code love seeing 413
western massachusetts call her from
4-1-3 what's going on
hey how's it going david good how are
you
not so bad i'm just calling regarding a
topic that you briefly touched on before
but you didn't really have a chance to
expand on it at the time okay uh you
were talking about
uh
legalization of drugs and you're mostly
for it but you had some reservations
i personally have always kind of sort of
been up the mindset
all drugs should be legal as long as uh
they're not as long as you're not able
to sell it to minors you're not hurting
anyone um but it sounds like you had
some reservations i was kind of curious
what your reservations about legalizing
so my reservations are merely i mean so
here's basically my thought i want to
decriminalize all drugs for sure
i want to legalize many of them i just
am unsure about the net effect of
legalizing uh black tar heroine for
recreational use i'm just not sure about
that i've not i've heard good arguments
for and against so i'm clear on
decriminalization i'm clear on
legalization of many drugs just on the
the the recreational legalization of
cocaine and heroin and stuff like that
i'm just unsure about
but outside of i understand i sort of
understand but outside of the
the effects that drugs can have on
someone and
the potential dangerous behaviors that
they can partake in such as for example
traveling under the influence which is
already illegal right or assaulting
someone or whatever like these are
behaviors that make the influence but
those behaviors are already
illegal right so they are so here's what
my concern would be here's what my
concern would be
with some of these drugs
the
at in any dose they are so destructive
to the individual
that it's hard for me to imagine them
not becoming destructive to society so
if you say listen someone's going to
smoke pot in their house they're not
going to drive it's illegal to do that
anyway it's very clear that people can
smoke pot or have edibles or whatever in
a way that is not going to have a
broader negative effect on society
something like uh
heroin for example i just don't know if
its use is truly just limited to the
individual who's choosing to use it and
that's it i don't know how if you have
children there's any way you can just
use heroin and it not affect children i
don't know if you have a job if there's
any way that you can use heroin and have
it not affect the people you work with
and whoever the customers are of the
business that's where i get hung up on
recreational legalization
of some of the the harder drugs and i'm
willing to have my mind changed for sure
okay all right i mean i still don't
totally agree but um i definitely don't
have the time to go back and forth with
you but i definitely appreciate your
your take on it thank you all right
where are you calling from by the way
oh yeah um actually i am calling from
connecticut i was originally in
springfield mass oh all right very good
all right very good always looking for
the 413 area code thank you so much if
you value what we do at the david pakman
show remember to support us on patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
hey david bernie has been saying that on
day one
he will legalize marijuana
is this actually possible
i sort of have dealt with this before
when a caller asked about it i it's not
possible so
what it really comes down to is when a
presidential candidate says on day one i
will do
this that the other thing
do they literally mean on their first
day or i guess the first day is the
inauguration do they do they mean their
first day in the office which would be
the second day or do they mean this is
generally going to be a priority of mine
because the reality is that when it
comes to something like legalizing
marijuana
the executive branch
certainly
could move
a drug from controlled substances
schedule one by directing the dea to do
it
even if they did that it doesn't happen
in one day it takes longer
but even if you do it after a few days
or realistically it's something that
would take weeks or months
it doesn't undo state level bans on
cannabis and you can't cancel those with
an executive order this actually has a
lot to do with states rights versus the
federal government so bernie could say
on day one
i have directed my attorney general
not to
do any
um prosecution raids any anything at all
uh when it comes to cannabis in any
state regardless of whether that state
has or has not legalized cannabis so
remember under barack obama's
administration obama directed the
justice department not to go into states
where marijuana was legal despite it
continuing to be illegal federally
bernie could say we're going to apply
that to every state even in idaho where
cannabis is illegal i still don't want
federal agencies going in there and
enforcing a federal drug policy or
whatever that's not a change to the law
but it does change the enforcement but
if cannabis is illegal in idaho idaho
police can continue to prosecute that
and to police it regardless of what it
is that bernie signs in the oval office
so
but what bernie could relatively quickly
do
would be immediately direct his attorney
general not to
police cannabis in any state
could start the process of rescheduling
cannabis away from schedule one but
that's that's basically it so the real
question comes down to it's actually a
semantic question when a candidate says
i will do x y or z on day one what does
that really mean does it does it mean
day one does it mean day two does it
mean the first month does it mean the
first year let me know what you think
and if you believe i am misunderstanding
the law around this i of course would
love to hear from you as well
uh let's go next to
um let's go to brent from lubbock i
presume lubbock texas is that right
brent
that is correct sir lubbock texas what's
going on there
not much man everybody's kind of we're
having some uh surges in covet cases so
yeah
you know not much is going on ready to
get uh
going back home next weekend to vote and
uh voting in person very good well what
can i do for you today
yeah i had a question um do you believe
that a biden administration will
decriminalize marijuana like they say
they will and on top of that do you
think they would potentially go a step
further than decriminalization since
mexico is uh poised to legalize
recreational use i think it's very
unlikely that during a first biden term
uh and
legalization happens and uh if you could
if you can mute your discord so we're
not hearing the constant beeps that
would be really really good in fact i
may just mute you and answer the rest of
it uh uh offline just so because it's
it's quite distracting
i do believe joe biden will de will try
to decriminalize
uh if he is able to do it is going to
depend on some factors beyond his
control
um but i i i do believe so i mean listen
in general
politicians when running for president
make promises that they can't always
keep and that sometimes they don't
intend to keep i don't think that's any
different with joe biden but i do
believe we are going to see particularly
if democrats take the senate um a good
faith effort made to decriminalize
marijuana and um i i hope we see it and
then i hope that that's just step one
and then we go we go further from there
all right let's hear from some more
people you can get in touch with me
through our discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go next to aaron
from los angeles california erin you're
on the air
hello david um i just had
i guess like some questions regarding um
i uh fcc standards and everything like
do you think that uh media companies do
you think the fcc should bring back the
fairness doctrine that they had back in
the 80s in order to make i guess
representation of diverse ideas on all
uh networks uh more palpable and uh
secondly like
just as someone that has a little bit of
experience in like i guess community
radio like i'm very very skeptical of
adding new regulations on like anything
new sec regulations in particular yeah i
think the cat is out of the bag on this
i do not think bringing because the
media landscape has changed so much i've
said before i don't think bringing back
the fairness doctrine is really going to
achieve
what maybe we hope it would achieve um
so much now of media consumption is
internet-based in all ways even people
in cars cars now have hot spots and i do
not think that in a way that is subject
to fcc jurisdiction you're really going
to be able to
accomplish
what one imagines you might be able to
accomplish with it so i think we need to
be fighting this in other ways and um we
you know we've talked before about what
those ways are but i would not waste i i
believe it's a waste of energy to focus
on an fcc based fairness doctrine to
sort of like fix the problems in media
right now
i i agree and i also just think that
like a lot of the uh just outright
regulations that uh have that the fcc
has just more harms independent creators
and like independent like outlets and
university outlets as opposed to you
know the major conservative political
talk networks that have been getting
away through loopholes for decades
yes there's no doubt about that and i
think that this is really going to come
from you know and for i hate to say this
because it's like
sometimes it feels like if you just put
in some law you fix everything when the
real solution is more complicated
the media problem is heavily based on
such a total lack of media literacy in
the country
where if we had
better
uh education around media literacy
we would not even need to be thinking
about a lot of these other solutions
that are much more
legally based and it's a long-term
solution i know you can't fix that
overnight but i continue to believe
that's where the solution lies
it's just so puzzling to me how that's
just such a major thing how media
literacy is just
not prevalent especially because
american education systems they
prioritize so much about reading and
writing yes at a young age from
kindergarten but it's not translating
over our english education isn't
teaching us these types of skills at all
and and
there are countries that start teaching
reading and writing later than the us
the everybody still ends up at the same
level but their media literacy ends up
ahead and i believe part of it is
this is just an opinion based on some
things i've read
at ages four five six instead of jumping
in prematurely into reading and writing
there's more about thinking
and i think it is something that just
should be thought about is all i'm
saying
okay
that's fair well thank you david all
right aaron from los angeles thanks very
much i do appreciate that great to hear
from you
let's go next
to um where do we want to go next i mean
there's just there's just so many people
that that want to talk
how about um how about colin from iowa
colin you're next
hello david can you hear me yes i can
well this is this is really an honor
david sir i've been uh such a fan of the
show the honor is my um
my my main choice for uh
any news that i do
beautiful um
who wow this actually happened i'm sorry
i'm a little star struck you're doing
great you're doing great did you have a
question today
i do have a question okay so
it's a little bit on the lighter side
i'd say i mean obviously i would talk
about covet or whatever but
this is just something that i've heard
recently among like a lot of liberals or
whatever it's about
okay well i'm from iowa obviously and
marijuana is illegal there
so i was like thinking
i think i said something along the lines
of like what if biden were to like the
present binder were to like
decriminalize marijuana if it's
decriminalized in a lot of states and
from what i've heard a lot of the
decriminalized states because i also
live in illinois like illinois is my
second home i guess you can say
and like it's it's uh
it's legal here and there really hasn't
been a problem there so
what do you think about like the
decriminalization of marijuana
nationally and if joe biden were to do
that how do you think that would affect
his popularity i think his popularity
would increase significantly if he were
to decriminalize i think there's a lot
of people who would prefer that joe
biden
federally legalize marijuana i think
there are different opinions as to
whether he could do that
but aside from that it's it's just not
going to be the next step i think the
next step the logical next step in the
progression would be
decriminalization i think it would be
incredibly popular overall if he did it
there would be people that are mad for
sure
but when you're talking about
decriminalizing you're not saying legal
recreational pot shops on every corner
the way right wingers love to fearmonger
about so they wouldn't be able to do
that they might say it's the first step
towards that but i think it would be
popular i would love for him to do it
and i i'm 100 in favor of that
yeah i totally agree david and for for
one thing for living in iowa like i'll
reveal a little bit about myself i live
in the quad cities so i'm on the iowa
side of the quad cities and i don't know
anybody personally that likes smokes but
from what i've heard a lot a lot of like
the people on my campus they will like
drive over just a few miles just to get
to like rock island to moline and then
they'd get the pot and then they'd bring
it back to davenport it i think that is
just kind of ridiculous so now i just
want to make sure i understand because
some people may not be familiar with all
of the you're saying they drive over
into illinois to buy the legal pot
yes the quad cities there's an iowa side
in the illinois side got it got it got
it since since the illinois side is the
legal side you would just drive over and
then pick it up right which
yeah that's that's just a quad city
secret for you got it all right well the
secret is now out uh very very much
appreciate the call and yes certainly uh
oh sorry uh a little quick on the
trigger finger there uh very much
appreciate the call i am in favor of
decriminalization and legalization i
think
[Music]
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
the nebia by moan quattro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 as much water but with a super high
pressure spray click the link below and
use the code pacman for 10 percent off
all nebia products